standard community property applies and
she is entitled half of the marital
assets or eleven point three nine five
million dollars
Jordan face Mac swoosh and that's yeah
that's not the end of the game that's
the beginning
[Music]
hey legal eagles D James Stone here
teaching you how to think like a lawyer
so you can crush law school you know
when I'm not teaching law students how
to kick ass in law school I'm often
watching courtroom movies myself but
unlike all of you normals I can't turn
off that lawyer part of my brain that's
always analyzing the courtroom scenes
for whether they're using a great tactic
that I should use in my own practice or
whether I should just pull out all of my
hair last time around I analyzed a few
of my favorite courtroom movies this
time around I'm reacting to some of the
legal movies that you suggested that I
watch if you have additional ideas for
movies that I haven't reacted to yet
please let me know in the comments I'm
always looking for new ideas and other
legal movies that I've never seen before
but let's dive right in we're gonna
start with one of the funniest courtroom
scenes of all time and that's in Liar
Liar mr. Reed it is out of sheer morbid
curiosity I'm allowing this freak show
to continue mrs. Cole you Dan mrs. Cole
is this copy of your driver's license
yes that's good he's laying foundation
with the witness it's a simple question
but you have to establish that a
document is what it purports to be and
he can do that through this woman who
owns the driver's license oh that's good
good foundation work it says here you're
a blonde are you if you don't remember
perhaps mr. Faulk will we can play the
tape again maybe it's on there brunette
thank you now let's see wait 105 yeah in
your bra Your Honor I am chip you would
normally you wouldn't try to set up your
own client and witness to be shown to be
a liar
but this is all part of sort of an
elaborate ruse so it obviously leads
somewhere but generally not the best
practice to impugn the reputation of
your own witness and client
oh wait 118 all right fine fine I'm 127
uh-huh and it says here you were born in
1964 but that's not true is it
is it no no let me get this straight
that would mean that you lied about your
age to make yourself older but why would
any woman wanna do that I changed it so
I could get married my client lied about
her age he was only 17 when she got
married which makes her a minor and in
the great state of California no minor
can enter into any legal contract
without parental consent
including prenuptial agreement
prenuptial agreements this contract is
void the fact that my client has been
written more than Seattle Slew is
irrelevant so this is a very clever
legal argument apart from all of the the
argument that that Jim Carrey is doing
in the scene you wouldn't yell it to the
courtroom and during the middle of an
examination there are some solid legal
arguments going on here specifically
he's making the argument that if a minor
enters into a contract the contract is
void because you're not allowed to have
an adult contract with a minor now
that's not exactly the way the law works
generally speaking what happens is a
minor can form a contract without
parental consent but what happens is
that when the minor reaches the age of
majority
they have the ability to either ratify
the contract or to exit the contract as
if it never happened so sometimes you
really need to be aware of a risk when
you form a contract with a minor and
there's a very famous case involving Bob
Dylan who entered into a studio contract
before he turned 18 and then I believe
he did not did not ratify the contract
afterwards but certainly that does not
end the case and Jim Carrey just can't
simply make an argument to the judge and
say that therefore I have won this case
because of this you know the single
piece of evidence what would actually
happen is that that would sort of start
the argument in this question in this
case this woman has been in this
marriage for decades it seems and of
course she enticed her husband into
entering this prenuptial agreement
through fraud now fraud is also often a
defense to a contract and there's also a
doctrine called unclean hands which
basically says that you cannot profit
from your own deception or deceit if if
you're entering into a contract or if
you have conducted some fraud so I don't
know where this particular argument ends
up it's a clever argument to say that
she was a minor and therefore she has
the ability to disassociate the contract
itself and rescind it but that is sort
of the beginning of the argument not the
end there are plenty of arguments that
the other side can make to say that just
because she was a minor doesn't end the
situation and the other person was
blameless because how could he know that
she was essentially conducting a fraud
on the marriage so there's probably
going to be a lot of analysis both in
marital law and contract law in
California to decide which way this one
goes it's it's an interesting argument
but that's absolutely not the end it's
it's going to be litigated quite a bit
from this point stead
community property applies and she is
entitled half of the marital assets or
eleven point three nine five million
dollars Jordan fades back swoosh and
that's the game yeah
nothing nothing
[Applause]
order in light of this new evidence the
court must rule in favor of mrs. Cole
she is hereby awarded half the marital
assets so a judge would never simply
issue a ruling immediately after one
particular piece of evidence especially
when there are gonna be good legal
arguments going back and forth in
reality the judge would probably ask for
separate briefing from both the
plaintiff and the defendant on this
thorny piece of law and and to find out
what the repercussions are from this
evidence that evidence may be
dispositive but it also may be totally
irrelevant
so the judge would take it all under
submission and give a ruling within a
couple of weeks and not rule from the
bench like this the next clip comes from
my cousin Vinnie one of my favorite
legal move here to show those eyeglasses
to the jury please thank you thank you
now mr. Tipton where are you wearing the
mat day no less you see you were 50 feet
away you made a positive ID witness
identification and and and and and and
and yet you were not wearing your
necessary prescription eyeglasses you
see this a lot in legal movies where the
examining attorney is literally inches
from the face of the witness in reality
you are not allowed to be anywhere near
the witness even a friendly witness and
the area between the judge and the
witness on one hand and the the tables
for counsel on the other it's called the
well the judicial well and you are not
allowed to even step foot in the well
without the express permission of the
judge so you see that all over the place
you see it in this particular shot he
would not be allowed to be that close to
the witness they reading glasses
ah well mister could you tell the court
what color eyes the defendants have
right hazel green no more questions
there is a rule amongst trial lawyers
that you do not ask a question of the
witness you don't know the answer to or
that you don't know the witness is going
to give you a favorable answer that's
why in cross-examination you're allowed
to issue leading questions which is a
question that implies the answer and you
would almost always want to use leading
questions when cross-examining a hostile
witness like this one to make sure that
you get the answer that you want and
often the tone and substance of the
question is more important than how the
witness actually answers but he really
shot himself in the foot by asking an
open-ended question that actually
bolstered the credibility of the witness
on the stand and really hurt his client
so that's rule number one
in terms of cross-examination you don't
want to do that mr. Gambini
your witness he's a tough one yes mr.
Tipton when you viewed the defendants
walking from their car into the
sac-o-suds what angle was your point of
view they was kind of walking toward me
when they entered the stone and when
they left what angle was your point of
view it was kind of walking away from me
so would you say you got a better shot
at I'm going in and not so much coming
out you could say that I did say that
would you say that yeah that is a good
tactic by Joe Pesci here
to really narrow the witness's testimony
and not just generally agree with the
statement but to get a positive
statement out of the witness along the
lines of what you want so he was right
to clarify from the witness is it
possible the two use to what also what
Joe Pesci is doing here is asking very
pointed questions that he's not
necessarily going to get an admission
that's going to win his case but he's
going to use that testimony later on in
the trial and so you have to be very
circumspect with respect to the the
witnesses that are on the stand
you can't win your entire case with one
witness so all he's doing is getting the
narrow point out that this witness saw
the two people coming in but didn't
really see their faces going out which
will be relevant to what other witnesses
and what other evidence shows later on
in the court and that's the best that
you can do and it's your job as the
attorney to tie that all together in
your closing statements it's not your
job to prove your case with one
particular witness so Joe Pesci's doing
a really good job here what you do in
your father crawfish tuneups oil changes
brake realigning engine rebuilds rebuild
some [ __ ] rear ends okay okay
but there's being an ex mechanic
necessarily qualify you as me an expert
on tire marks no thank you goodbye this
is pretty good back and forth between
the attorney and the witness when you
offer a witness as an expert the other
side is allowed to probe that and
question whether or not they are a
sufficient expert in some areas so that
they can offer an opinion the difference
between a person who just tells what
they know what they personally saw and
an expert is an expert is allowed to
give an opinion based on potentially
evidence but not actually having
personally seen or heard or written or
whatever the evidence that's in front of
them so that's why it's important to
make sure that they
meet the minimum threshold for an expert
opinion and that's what the attorneys
are doing here gianna ms Vito's
expertise is in general automotive
knowledge it is in this area that her
testimony will be applicable now if mr.
Trotta wishes to what diana witness as
to the extent of her expertise in this
area I'm sure he's gonna be more than
satisfied that's a good retort by joe
peshi who responds to the argument that
she is not an expert in tire marks but
is an expert in a very narrow area and
that is the only area that he's going to
ask for an expert opinion generally this
would happen in briefing and not
actually on the witness stand but it
could happen on the witness stand too
and he's essentially making a proffer
that he's only gonna ask certain
questions of Marisa Tomei and the term
that he uses voir dire and it's
pronounced differently in different
places some places it's called voir dire
that is the correct term for examining
an expert on their suppose at expertise
you would also conduct Vlade roar voir
dire of a jury if you're asking if they
are sufficient to sit on the jury in a
particular case as well
okay all right now Oh miss Vito being an
expert on general automotive knowledge
can you tell me what would the correct
ignition timing be on a 1955 Bel Air
Chevrolet with a 327 cubic inch engine
and a full barrel carburetor it's a
[ __ ] question does that mean that
you can't answer it's a [ __ ]
question it's impossible answer
impossible because you don't know the
answer nobody could answer that question
Your Honor I move to disqualify miss
Beto as an expert witness can you answer
the question no it is a trick question
why is it a trick question
watch this Chevy didn't make a 327 and
55 4 3 2017 come out 262 and it wasn't
offered in the Bel Air with the floor
barrel carb till 64 however in 1964 the
correct ignition timing would be 4
degrees before top dead center well
despite the questions being a little
argumentative the big problem there is
that he asked a question he did not know
the answer to and he didn't know how the
witness was going to answer it so he
ends up looking like a fool and
bolstering the credibility of the
witness and while he got a little close
and was in the in the well of the court
that's a that's a menorah your honor
and he sees that he's beaten and he
retreats that's the the way a smart
lawyer would react you just move on and
you deal with the the testimony that
comes out later this next scene comes
from the movie The Insider it was
correct in other words it acts as a drug
objectively form a question it acts as a
drug on object X as an object here your
objections been recorded she typed it
into her little machine over there it's
on the record this is
is a really interesting scene that you
you really don't see much of in the
media this is a deposition so you are
allowed to ask questions of a particular
witness the witness has to give their
testimony under oath and it's all
recorded by a stenographer as if that
witness was on the stand but this takes
place before trial this is not part of
the trial proceedings it's part of the
discovery proceedings before trial ever
happens so what generally happens in the
deposition is you have the witness the
attorney for the witness the attorney
for the other side and the stenographer
to write down every word that the
witness says and that becomes part of
the deposition record and the opposing
attorney is allowed to make objections
to the questions that you're asking
but nothing really happens you're just
objecting so that you can preserve that
objection for a later time in case the
question is ever asked in court if you
fail to make your objection during the
deposition and the same question is
asked at the stand you have waived your
objection and you can't object at a
later time so you're preserving the
record what's going on here is something
that happens rarely but it does happen
which is where you have this giant room
because it's a huge class action and you
have an attorney for one side and then
you know hundreds or dozens of attorneys
for the other side in this case the
insider is the real-life story of the
tobacco litigation that happened in the
early 90s so the tobacco industry
obviously has an army of lawyers and
they're trying to stop this witness from
testifying and so he's making his
objection and he specifically says I
object to the form of of the question
which in the South is generally the only
thing you're allowed to do in a
deposition you can't object to hearsay
you can't object to speculation you can
only object to the form of the question
so that's what he's doing but he's doing
it over and over and over again to try
and prevent the witness from testifying
so it's a common tactic it's not exactly
what you should be doing but it's true
to life so this could be the actual
dialogue from
life deposition I'm not sure but stuff
like that definitely happens so now I'll
proceed with my deposition of my witness
that's right he the opposing side has
made their objections they've objected
to the form of the question many times
and then the other one the other
attorney just moves forward and says you
made your objection you preserve to the
record and now I'm moving on and I'm
asking my question does it wagon I am
instructing you not to answer that
question in accordance to the terms of
the contractual obligations undertaken
by you not to disclose any information
about your work at the Brown &
Williamson tobacco company so he has
instructed the witness not to answer and
that usually comes up only when you're
dealing with privilege issues so for
example if you ask a question that
infringes on the attorney-client
privilege then you would instruct the
witness not to answer it so an opposing
attorney can't ask for example what you
discussed with your attorney in that
situation you would instruct your client
not to answer on the basis of that
privilege this is a different situation
though because the tobacco company is
effectively a third party here so this
doctor no longer works for the tobacco
companies so they probably can't
instruct someone who is a third party to
them not to answer usually it's up to
the witness whether they are going to
follow the attorneys instruction or not
and so it's a little a little tenuous
whether you can instruct a witness not
to answer on the basis of a contractual
obligation and by the way usually
non-disclosure agreements don't hold up
in the face of a court proceeding
because then you know that would be a
contrary to public policy so using a
non-disclosure agreement to to try and
prevent a witness from testifying is is
an interesting tactic but I don't think
it would hold up and in accordance with
the force and effect of the temporary
restraining order that has been entered
against you by the court in the state of
Kentucky
that means you don't talk so that's
another situation that's interesting in
that there is supposedly a restraining
order from another state ordering him
not to disclose it so it's an
interesting situation and I know that in
real life this was a big part of this
litigation whether this former doctor or
this doctor who was a former employee of
the tobacco company was bound by this
non-disclosure agreement
but this interchange between the two
attorneys and the objections and the
instructions not to answer that dialogue
is pretty realistic and you know
sometimes you get these big rooms this
is a little bit more dramatic then you
would have in a real deposition even in
one that has dozens of attorneys you're
really just in a big conference room
sitting around in a table no one is
standing up walking around asking
questions you know you know pretending
like you're in court it's all just
everybody's sitting down and you're not
gonna get this these sort of histrionics
but the dialogue itself is true to life
and in these big class actions you can
get situations where you have lots of
parties in a deposition and sometimes it
can get pretty heated to mr. motley we
have rights here Boyd you've got rights
and less ups and downs and middles so
what you don't get to instruct anything
around here this is not North Carolina
not South Carolina nor Kentucky this is
the sovereign state of Mississippi's
proceeding wipe that smirk off your face
dr. waggons deposition will be part of
this record and I'm going to take my
witness's testimony whether the hell you
like it or not yeah and so there you
have it he's saying that the other side
can't instruct the witness not to answer
and in the absence of a court order in
this particular court that attorney is
doing the right thing and he's just
moving forward and the attorneys can
argue on whether that testimony is
admissible at a later date but the
important thing is to get that test
down on paper so that you at least have
the option to use it later regardless of
you know whether it was proper in the
first place and and when you get these
disputes in a deposition you you have a
game of chicken usually the other side
will say that they're gonna shut the
deposition down and potentially face the
ire of the court unless they can
convince the court that what the other
side was doing was so crazy that the
deposition shouldn't move forward so you
know you got to be very careful on both
sides and when in doubt just move
forward and ask the questions so you can
get some testimony on the record all
right the next clip is from the devil's
advocate mr. Clinton let me ask you this
do you think it's a juror you would be
able to set aside any prior opinion you
might hold about the Savings and Loan
industry that was the question sir
what do I like bankers this is a law
dear of a panel of jurors a lot of
people will experience this this very
thing when they get called for jury duty
one side is asking questions of the
jurors they're trying to figure out
number one can they be impartial but
number two more importantly are they
more likely to vote for your side over
the others and the attorney has asked a
classic question about can you be
impartial for a particular defendant or
plaintiff and the next best thing to
getting someone who you think is going
to vote for you in the trial is to show
that they can't be impartial and have
the judge dismiss them yeah so you you
you get a certain number of peremptory
challenges which means that you can get
rid of potential jurors for no reason at
all but you only get a certain amount of
those but you know if you can convince
the judge to get rid of the jurors for
you then you get an unlimited number of
those so it's a game of cat and mouse
between the attorneys the jurors on the
other side
Your Honor may I have a minute place to
confer with my colleagues you may dump
them while you write let's get rid of
number four six and I'd say blues number
twelve except with prosecutors gonna
[ __ ] up and do it for us six in a major
case you actually might have jury
consultants behind you it's it's very
common to consult with not only your
co-counsel who are watching the jurors
while you're asking questions and they
might have some intuition about who they
should keep and who should who they
should get rid of but you also might
have consultants who all they do all day
long is try to pick favorable juries for
you so there aren't any consultants here
because they're relying on the acumen of
Keanu Reeves but you might see one in
real life if the case is big enough if
the dollar amount is worth it you're
kidding right
she's my first choice she's my first
pass and for
with the dreadlocks that's crazy that's
the defendants sure if I have a solid
did you see his shoes yeah it's
unfortunate that there is a lot of sort
of stereotyping that goes on when you're
selecting and a jury I think that's sort
of what they're alluding to here with
with that particular pick or dismissal
there are laws that say you cannot get
rid of you know every minority that's on
a jury for example you know you've got a
you've got a thread a very fine line in
some of these cases so it's unfortunate
that there's sort of profiling people
based on that but it happens in real
life unfortunately maybe done in Florida
you are the next big thing this is New
York Manhattan
we're not squeezing oranges here he
polishes those shoes every night he
makes his own clothes he may look like a
brother with an attitude to you but I
see a man with shotgun under his bed and
woe betide the creature who steps into
this garden and number six your favorite
she's damaged goods there's a science to
picking a good jury but there's also a
lot of intuition that goes on too and I
don't know that it would be so so crazy
is what Keanu Reeves is talking about
here but you know there's an art and a
science to it it can really make a
difference in your case so those are
some of my favorite legal movies if
you'd like to see more lawyer Reax
videos or hear about my law school
experience please click on this short
playlist that I put together it includes
the latest video I did on law school
horror stories I think you'll really
like it please click Subscribe if you
like this video so that you never miss
the next one and otherwise I'll see you
in the next video